steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd steadymd.com
pacman to get started we are in the
middle of one of the most
interesting stock market related stories
that i can remember in a really long
time and when i say we're in the middle
of it we are really in the middle of it
so i hope to do justice to what's gone
on
so far and the way i'm describing this
is a game stop short squeeze
that is potentially going to nuke some
hedge funds
and let's just start at at the beginning
uh
companies exist and some of them are
publicly traded
meaning you can buy shares in those
companies i know i'm going
very very basic here one such company is
gamestop gamestop is a chain
of stores where you can buy video games
and of course
with the advent of buying video games
online and having them delivered
digitally through for example
steam a service that uh um
is available to download games um
gamestop
had been struggling for some time
coronavirus
then hit which dramatically decreased
the number of people
that were doing in-person shopping
especially for something like video
games when you can just get them on the
internet already
so gamestop stock started to decline
and this led to a lot of people and
subsequently
hedge funds short selling the stock now
what does it mean to short sell a stock
again we're not
going to do an hour on short selling but
the the gist of it is as follows
the way most of us think about investing
in stocks
for what we might call the long term is
that we are long on a stock meaning
you buy it at a certain price the plan
is to hold it
hopefully the price goes up and then you
sell the stock if you buy it fifty
dollars a share
sell it a hundred dollars a share you
make fifty dollars per share
but you can do essentially the reverse
you can short
sell a stock and what that means is you
are placing a bet that the stock goes
down
rather than up and instead of first
doing the buying and then doing the
selling
you are first selling borrowed stock
and then you are repurchasing it in the
future and with that same
fifteen hundred dollar number in reverse
you can make fifty dollars per share
if there's a stock trading now at a
hundred dollars per share
that i believe in the future will trade
at fifty i can
borrow and sell shares for a hundred
dollars
when it drops to fifty i buy them
for fifty dollars and now i've made
fifty dollars per share
the risk is there's only so much a stock
can go
down zero meaning if you invest a
thousand dollars
that could end up being worth zero and
you're out a thousand dollars
when you short sell there's really no
limit
to how much you can lose you can borrow
shares and if they go from a thousand to
two thousand dollars you've
lost a thousand dollars but if they go
from one thousand to three thousand
dollars
you've now lost two thousand dollars and
as you can see there's
no limit to the amount that you can lose
indeed
what took place is that a bunch of
different hedge funds and big investors
were
certain of the demise of gamestop stock
they shorted it and a
now this is where there start to be
different opinions
about exactly the the sequence but the
long and short of it is that
some online uh uh enclaves where
stock trades are discussed including a
subreddit called wall street bets
pointed out hey look at this there are a
lot of
shorts here that could potentially be
squeezed
i am going to start buying and buying
and buying this
stock that is exactly what tons of
people did
and the va the price of the stock
exploded
meaning that these hedge funds are now
very upside down
soon many of these hedge funds are going
to remember you're
first selling and then buying when you
short
they are going to have to buy and they
are going to have to buy
at way more than they sold putting them
under water and in fact putting some
hedge funds
as far as we are being told at risk of
insolvency
at risk of going out of business um
a few interesting takes on this uh
congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez tweeted gotta
admit
it's really something to see wall
streeters with a long history of
treating our economy as a casino
complain about a message board of
posters
also treating the market as a casino our
friend anna casparian from the young
turks tweeting tweeting
so market manipulation by federal
reserve pumping money into failing banks
and corporations is okay
but reddit users rallying gamestop is
wrong and must be regulated
the entire stock market is disconnected
from reality funny how quickly the
financial press
cries for hedge funds so here's my take
on this
this run-up of the stock price of
gamestop
is no more wrong than the other types of
speculation including the shorting that
others do
just because it's being organized on
reddit instead of by hedge funds high up
uh in in skyscrapers in wash in new york
city
doesn't make it any more right or wrong
what this does expose again in case you
forgot
is that the stock market is not the
economy and so
much like when we say oh stocks are up
but it's hedge funds making money that's
not really the economy
the posters on reddit that are doing
this now making a bunch of money it's
also not the economy it just reminds us
the stock market is not the economy
now uh these hedge funds made
risky deals and if the stock mark if the
stock price kept declining they would
have made a bunch of money
it went up so now they're at risk of
losing money
there are now a bunch of hedge funds
that are saying this isn't okay and we
need regular this shouldn't be allowed
to happen well
hold on a second if you want to do risky
things
it's risk reward the possibility of a
big reward comes with risk
you can't now say you want the big
reward but you want the risk taken off
the table by the government they are
saying it
but it is extraordinarily hypocritical
now there's a really important
uh aspect to this which is that many of
the
commentaries the hot takes are people
debating
whether the wall street bets posters
who are running up the price of the
stock are sincerely buying game stop
stock
because they believe it's a good company
with good prospects
or whether they are ironically buying
gamestop
stock or cynically buying the stock
that doesn't matter that could not be
less relevant
that's what hedge funds do do you think
that hedge funds and other investors are
saying
we only buy long or short sell a stock
based on our sincerely held deep down
beliefs about
the ethics and business prospects and
management of the company
no they're making speculative bets
either way and the idea about oh
these aren't genuine pumpers what
difference does it make that's the whole
point
of uh many of the people who have been
saying the behavior by the hedge funds
is predatory
and cynical now they are saying well no
no the
the wall street bets people are the
cynical ones
who thought to apply that to when kelly
leffler
senator former senator from georgia made
those stock moves
uh once she was briefed about what was
happening and what was in coming with
the pandemic
was she saying ooh i don't think the
management of these company
no she predicted that there were going
to be
uh general shocks to the system that
would make these
shares be worth less and so she decided
to sell it wasn't she thought it was a
good company or she thought the
management team over the long
she just got out in order to avoid
losing money
and by the way what's a stock buyback at
its core when a company buys back its
own stock
the point is to pump the price back up
it is not well we feel so confident in
our business model that we are going to
invest in our own
come on come on you that we it would be
cynical to
think that's what's going on so there's
a case here to be made for transaction
taxes which eliminates this issue of are
they genuine or cynical stock trades
and uh why would you expect anything
else
when this is the way that the stock
market operates there's two sides to it
and i am as curious as everybody else to
see what happens with this
i am thrilled to report to you that the
joe biden administration
has frozen u.s weapons sales
to saudi arabia the biden administration
is freezing two big arms deals with
saudi arabia as well as the united arab
emirates
and these were approved very late in the
trump administration and they are now
on pause this is related to the sale of
some
f-35 jets as well as attack drones to
the uae
and a very big supply of various
munitions
elements of munitions to saudi arabia
these are stopped and they are going to
be reviewed this would be a
huge policy shift from the trump era and
really a big policy shift in general for
the united states state state department
um and we have been talking about the
has it been i think it's been a decade
that i've been talking about
the perverse relationship with saudi
arabia on this program
the senior u.s official who commented on
this
said that these are routine
administrative actions typical to any
transition you just
were putting a pause to review pending
arms deals
and they sort of are seemingly trying to
downplay the geopolitical significance
but i don't think it should be
downplayed
let's wait and see what they decide if
then they say in a month oh yeah we're
going to just go through with it
uh well then maybe really this is no big
deal but
so far this appears to be a significant
a significant decision that's being made
i like what i see
now uh if we think about
engagement with the progressive base of
the democratic party
as well as more left-leaning
independents this is a good step
by the biden administration of course it
remains to be seen
what ultimately happens with these
paused deals
but so far there is a lot to be
optimistic about and and very
importantly
this reminds us both sides aren't the
same trump
spent his administration bragging about
arms deals with saudi arabia when asked
about
stopping the deals over the murder of
jamal khashoggi
he said well there's a lot of jobs out
there remember this
jamal khashoggi the journalist the saudi
journalist
was he murdered by the saudis and did
the prince
give the order to kill him well nobody
knows yet but we'll probably be able to
find out
it's being investigated it's being
looked at very very strongly
and we would be very upset and angry if
that were the case as of this moment
they deny it and did not
deny it vehemently could it be them yes
jared your son-in-law got on the phone
and asked
the prince did he what did he deny it
they deny it they denied every way you
can imagine in the not too distant
future i think we'll know
an answer what are your options let's
say they did
what are your options would you consider
imposing sanctions
as a bipartisan group of senators have
proposed what depends on what the
sanction is i'll give you an example
they are ordering military equipment
everybody in the world wanted that order
russia wanted it china wanted it we
wanted it
we got it so would you cut that off
what i don't want to do boeing lockheed
raytheon all these i don't want to hurt
jobs
here's another one where donald trump
was asked about the same thing
be in favor of stopping a country from
spending a hundred and ten
billion dollars which is an all-time
record
and letting russia have that money and
letting china have that money because
all they're going to do is say that's
okay
we don't have to buy it from boeing
we don't have to buy from lockheed we
don't have to buy it from
raytheon and all these great companies
we'll buy it from russia
we'll buy it from china so what good
does that do us
there are other things we can do now
donald trump is not wrong i mean
trump is right that there are u.s there
are
jobs in the united states connected
to selling weapons to saudi arabia
that's true
what makes the freeze all the more
notable
and if they stick to it and cancel the
deals
all the more brave is that there are
jobs connected to this and there will be
people who say
anything that creates jobs must be done
no matter how unethical or immoral or
counter to our stated values as a
country
if joe biden sticks with not going
through with these sales
there will be some jobs on the line
that's true
and it will make what is a morally
correct decision
all all the more uh significant i didn't
expect to see this yesterday
and i am quite pleased we will follow it
to see where it ends up
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter deepak
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me and my medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakin show is a primarily
viewer and listener supported
independent media program i would love
it if you grabbed a membership at
joinedpakman.com and we do an extra show
every day for our members it's the
award-winning bonus show
they are awards we give out so keep that
in mind but they are awards nonetheless
and you can sign up at joinpakman.com uh
we have
a great discussion forum on reddit you
can find it at davidpakman.com
reddit we are approaching 30 000
of our viewers and listeners uh
subscribed
to the subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit a few interesting posts i spotted
this morning
uh oklahoma is indeed trying to return
its two million dollar stockpile of
hydroxychloroquine
how funny and sad is it that nobody
talks about hydroxychloroquine anymore
there was a period of time where
hydroxychloroquine was being touted by
donald trump
by sean hannity by all sorts of random
people who were pretending to know about
coronavirus treatments that had not yet
been peer reviewed
and much like we said at the time it
was something to look into and study and
much like many other possible
coronavirus treatments it turns out it
was not actually
effective at preventing reducing the
severity of
or treating coronavirus and now oklahoma
sitting on two million dollars worth of
pills and they are trying to return them
yes
i i have not forgotten about the
hydroxychloroquine fiasco
another user posting that intellectual
dark web
users followers believe i
am now a member of the intellectual dark
web and indeed there
apparently there's a post on the
intellectual dark web subreddit
which lists me along with
um a whole bunch of people
some of some of whom i don't i don't
actually know um along with sam harris
and jordan peterson and others as being
part of the intellectual dark web
i don't know how my name got on that
list i also see sam harris's name is on
the list and i thought he turned in his
uh credentials
for the intellectual dark web and said
he was bailing um yeah i don't really
know anything about it i got a bunch of
emails saying david you're now part of
the idw
i've never been asked to join i i've
never
said anything one way or the other i
don't even know the status of the
intellectual dark web at this point to
be perfectly frank i haven't heard much
about it
for months and months or even more than
a year
so the the status of the idw
to me is unknown my membership or lack
thereof is also
nebulous so i have nothing to say about
it i'm as confused as others are
and lastly yes the bizarre
stories equivalent to the obama tan suit
scandal about joe biden are starting a
bunch of people sent me
this article that was posted on
foxnews.com
joe biden administration under fire
for removing an oval office statue
of winston churchill um yeah listen
we predicted this we predicted this when
we knew joe biden
was going to be the next president which
by the way was in early november
it wasn't january 19th when some other
people finally realized biden would be
president
or even january 20th the republican
right wing media apparatus was very
quickly going to go back to all of their
normal tricks talking about the debt and
deficit
talking about how can we afford this how
can we afford that
is climate change overblown and uh
equivalence
to the obama wore a tan suit at a
serious event and that was bad
scandal so no surprise whatsoever and i
do expect it to continue
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit this is very exciting but also a
little bit depressing because it's not
going to pass the senate
house and senate democrats have
introduced legislation
to make washington d.c a state the 51st
state of the united states this is
something we've been talking about for
months and months
the measure was reintroduced in the
house by a delegate eleanor
holmes norton she's a democrat who
represents the district of columbia
and the senate version was introduced by
senator tom carper from delaware
as of tuesday evening norton says she
has more than 200 co-sponsors in the
house
but it appears as though there is no
chance whatsoever
that this is going to pass in the senate
democrats control the senate with the
50-50 split and kamala harris as a
tie-breaking vote
but democrats would need to overcome a
filibuster on this issue which requires
60 votes this is not something you can
pass via budget reconciliation meaning
democrats need to find 10 republicans
willing to vote
yes washington dc should me should be a
state
republican lawmakers for a long time
have opposed washington d.c statehood
as you and i have talked about before
representation
in washington dc would likely be
overwhelmingly democratic meaning two
additional democratic senators
and uh that is not something that
republicans want to see now
of course the reality is that on the
merits this makes obvious sense
even by republican so-called values if
the republican party were actually
principled
this should be a unanimous vote in favor
of washington d.c
being a state washington dc is being
taxed without
representation big government is
uh ruling over these washington dc
folks without them having a voice
if this were utah that didn't have
two senators republicans would have
voted
i don't know decades ago and said oh
utah absolutely must have two senators
but the difference is
utah's very red and washington dc is
very blue
but if the principle here is that people
deserve representation you're paying
taxes
why do some taxpayers get senate
representation
and other taxpayers do not it is because
they know who lives in washington d.c
and they know how washington dc would
vote and so it's not really about
principles or democracy anymore
uh if you are an american you should
have at least
one member of the house representing you
and two senators
how is this even a debate well it's a
debate
because of the uh false claims of
values and principles when it's
convenient to them for republicans
and abandoning those same principles
when it no longer is convenient
washington dc has more than 100
000 more people living in it than the
entire state of wyoming
okay if washington dc was a state
they would have their own national guard
they could have responded on january 6th
without having to
depend on all of these other players to
say fine fine fine we're going to send
national guard
washington dc is the 20th largest city
in the united states
that's not even the dc metro that's
washington dc
itself they pay federal taxes they pay
local
you know they pay all sorts of taxes but
they have no senators
it is absolutely ridiculous and i
hope that joe biden will actually make
this an
issue there have been questions about
uh is how much of a of an issue is this
going to be for the biden harris
administration
the people of washington dc deserve to
be represented just as much as the
people of other states
we know why republicans aren't for it it
is not for any principle
other than the principle of we are
hypocrites and just do things that favor
our party
that's the only principle that
republicans are abiding by
and adhering to when they say yeah we
don't think washington dc
should be a state now we've talked also
about puerto rico puerto rico
i believe both dc and puerto rico should
be states if puerto rico wants to be a
state of course
um the difference is politically and
again for me it's the principle so i
don't care about this
it's less clear that puerto rico would
probably not be
unanimously democratic in his
representation uh it's it's
there's a larger conservative contingent
in puerto rico
i would expect that there would probably
be
at least one member of the house that is
a republican that would win
in puerto rico senate i don't know
but the principle here makes me come to
no other conclusion then
dc should be a state puerto rico should
be a state now i know people will say
well what about american samoa what
about guam okay let we're we're dealing
with puerto rico and washington dc right
now
send me your thoughts about this what
could convince
10 democr 10 republicans in the senate
to say yeah i will vote for dc statehood
let me know your thoughts we'll have
continued coverage of this on our
instagram page
at david pakman show and you can follow
me on instagram as well
at david.pacman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's join
pakman.com if the normal prices strike
you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
today i'm going to be speaking with
david livingstone smith who's a
professor of philosophy at the
university of new england
in maine and also author of the book on
inhumanity dehumanization and how to
resist it
i really appreciate your time today
thank you david
so to set the stage for the conversation
when we talk about
dehumanization and inhumanity
there are a lot of ways that we could
sort of define those ideas but what what
do you mean when you talk about that
well dehumanization is a word that's
used in so many different ways
i mean even in the scholarly literature
what i mean by demonization
is the attitude of conceiving of other
people
as subhuman creatures and
in history there are so many different
um examples of when we can say that
this dehumanization took place there are
times where it can take place
um by people who are trying to uh
justify horrible acts of violence there
are times when dehumanization might even
be
a coping mechanism by someone exposed to
extremely harsh or difficult conditions
in in some way shape or form
what are some of the different ways that
in human history this has manifested
well almost always dehumanization
is the product of propaganda so it's not
something that spontaneously arises in
the human mind
rather it's the result of people in
positions of power who want us to do
terrible things to one another and the
paradigmatic example of that
is is genocide so if those in power
those who are
in positions of authority can convince
us
that these others that they wish us to
harm
are dangerous toxic subhuman creatures
that we must destroy on our own
self-defense
then that allows us to overcome a very
natural resistance human beings have to
doing awful things to one another i i'm
thinking of so many of the uh
books i've read about the holocaust and
concentration camps
and the way in which uh concentration
camp
uh guards uh ss nazi soldiers etc
um by by propaganda i mean quite
literally the story that hitler was
telling about about jews and
and about some others was about these
people
are not really human the way we are but
there's also interestingly
in some of the memoirs of survivors of
concentration camps
they said they also experienced the sort
of dehumanization even of their peers
which they saw almost as a survival
instinct
which which is is that a different
mechanism
well yes we'd have to go into some
detail about what they had
in mind but certainly people who are the
victims of dehumanization
are quite aware generally that they're
seen as
subhuman creatures i mean we find this
in the example of the holocaust
the two examples that i use most of my
work are the holocaust
which by the way has centuries
old roots in european anti-semitism
jews had been dehumanized since the
since the
12th century in europe
and also the brutal oppression of black
people
in the united states particularly in the
aftermath of the american civil war
and in both those instances the victims
of dehumanization
were well aware that they were seen
as subhuman creatures
monsters demons vermin
as a historical note uh what is the
is i'm curious whether you're aware of i
know of of uh anti-semitism based in the
idea of jews bringing the plague
uh and i i'm i don't remember if that's
13th century or 14th century is that the
earliest example you're aware of or is
there something
prior to that well dehumanization of
jews we've we
find it sporadically earlier
so in the gospel of john jews are
described as offspring of satan
right so that's very early christian
uh root of some anti-semitic ideas
right so if you're the offspring of
satan you're demonic yes
this idea of the demonic jew persisted
but it really took a terrible turn
during the first crusade when christians
marched off
to to the holy land to win it back from
the infidel
and along the way they decided to
attack the infidel in their midst
remember jews were the only religious
minority who were permitted to survive
in europe
right um and it's from this point
onward that jews are racialized they're
seen as an alien and inferior race and
seen as
demonic devilish biologically different
even it was believed that jewish men
menstruated that jews had
horns and tails and and so on
and so it just picks up there and then
after the bubonic plague
of the mid 14th century
uh it it gets really really really bad
when it comes to the um
i i guess we would the dehumanizers so
to speak
sometimes words or terms like
they are monsters they are animals etc
are applied which in a sense is a
dehumanization of the dehumanizers
is the is that a pro is that something
we should be concerned about doing are
there risks
yeah absolutely we should be concerned
about that monsters are fictional
no one is a monster hitler was not a
monster i'm jewish i can say that
hitler was not a monster gobbles was not
a monster
these are human beings and it would
really benefit us
if we considered them as holding up a
mirror to what is
possible for any human being you know we
are all vulnerable there's no
vaccination against humanizing attitudes
is it uh is the term dehumanization
relevant to
i'm thinking back a few months now
during the coronavirus pandemic
the lieutenant governor of texas dan
patrick
gave this viral interview i think it was
on fox news where he said something
about
listen uh i i would be willing to
sacrifice myself i think grandma
or or so to speak something like that
they're willing to sacrifice themselves
for the good of the economy by which he
really met the stock market
is that a sort of dehumanization that
we've seen during coronavirus of
when you see a number four thousand died
or three thousand died
and you just sat in your house and
worked from home it doesn't really feel
that that that difference of a thousand
you don't feel it in any real way
it seems like that's a form of
dehumanization some people would call it
dehumanization i prefer a
very fine-grained notion of what
dehumanization is
so there are a bunch of related
attitudes but you see
i think if we're to understand what i
consider
the most toxic form of these attitudes
which i reserve the term dehumanization
for
we need to get a good understanding of
how it works otherwise
we don't have a chance in hell of
dismantling it
right so i call what call that
callousness
and of course what he's saying in fact
is he's willing to sacrifice the lives
of life of grandma
right grandma isn't speaking there are
are there uh things you've observed
during the pandemic that you would
apply the term dehumanization to oh yes
yes yes so
what's gone on in this pandemic as is
typical
by the way of earlier pandemics
is uh xenophobia so
the pandemic is is blamed on others
racial others because race and
dehumanization are very closely tied
together
and then when you start talking about
people
as diseased as dangerous
outsiders you are either well on the way
towards humanization
or actually there you see it's
it's it's not regarded as especially
acceptable
to call people demons and monsters
anymore
so we have substitute terms they're
diseased
they're criminal they're dangerous
they're bad to the bone
and what we get in this pandemic and in
previous pandemics
is an upsurge in that kind of feeling
which has historically led to all sorts
of
of horrible things it seems as though
dehumanizat
the rhetoric of dehumanization probably
has some specific
overlap with authoritarian regimes and
authoritarianism
is it can we can you talk about that a
little bit yeah sure so there are two
ways that
but i think the first question to to
address is
why dehumanization in the first place
and the reason i believe
is that human beings being highly social
animals
have difficulty performing acts
of lethal or even sub-lethal violence on
one another we're just equipped with
these inhibitions
but those are very inconvenient if you
want to oppress
and exterminate others
so as i said
people in positions of power of
authority
can tell us you know these others they
might look like you and me
they might look like human beings but
really deep downward counts on the
inside
they're something else and that is
absolutely typical
of authoritarian going on fascist
it seems almost like a tool that's
necessary for such a regime
to advance its its propaganda to
you talked about the role of propaganda
and dehumanization early it seems that
for
for authoritarian regimes that
dehumanization of the other is
is necessary for them to advance their
goals it's certainly
extremely helpful i would say maybe near
necessary
hesitate to say anything is necessary
but it's
it is certainly it is certainly helpful
sometimes the demonizing ideology is
distributed through a community
so as i say in the first chapter of on
inhumanity i grew up in the deep south
in the 50s and 60s and their demonizing
attitudes towards black people they were
that
was in the air you breathe a rush
limbaugh
say to propagate these things what what
how casual was the dehumanization when
you were growing up in the south
oh it was just it just as you know we
would say the sky is up and the earth is
down
black people who were not referred to by
that word
sure by the way uh were seen as
filthy subhuman
animals i mean that was kids in my high
school would brag
about hunting black kids with their bb
guns
on weekends for sport um
that's that's uh and do you rem
was the was there a gradual transition
out of that that aligned with the civil
rights era 1964 civil rights act what
did it lag
that it it you know there's a gradual
transition but also a re-entrenchment
i mean these things have not gone away
still
right we like to think about the new
south but these are
these things take a very very very long
time to change
right they they do not disappear quickly
they can remain
latent relatively invisible for
a long period of time and then the
social environment changes a little bit
someone in power like our former
president gives permission
for certain kinds of attitudes and bang
you know the confederate flags are out
what um where where do things like uh
eugenics and phrenology play into this
because on the one hand
you know stuff about measuring skull
ratios and all this stuff it
in a sense it's very human in that we're
looking at the minutia
of of the characteristics of the human
form
but the it's its use seems to be
dehumanizing
well it's it's actually a bit worse than
that so if we look
at the history of scientific racism in
the united states
during the period when these practices
were beginning to flourish
eugenics is a bit later but certainly
the skull measurement
work the premier scientific authorities
in the country described black people
as literally another species
they were learned
papers on on this and mixed race people
were seen as
literally as hybrids between different
species
so these see you see there the the
dehumanizing attitude is endorsed by
scientific authority it could be
scientific authority it could be
political it's anyone who has that kind
of
influence right yeah i mean that that
makes and i know you write about this in
the book it brings me to the topic of
climate change and climate
science what do you see maybe to the
audience it's not obvious the connection
between
dehumanization the way we've talked
about in authoritarian regimes and and
so on
and the connection to climate change
yeah
well uh the the aspect of climate change
that's most salient for me and my work
on dehumanization
is that i think catastrophic climate
change which i don't think anyone's
going to do anything about i think we're
well too late for that and there's
insufficient motivation
despite the fine words that are are said
is
going to create a situation which is a
perfect storm
for really dangerous
forms of dehumanization there will be
refugee
problems like the world has never known
you know when when the population of
bangladesh spills into india
um and
resources run short and infrastructures
break down this is going to generate
intense xenophobia
and i would put good money
on dehumanizing rhetoric of the worst
most genocidal sort is the only way to
prevent it to prevent the climate
refugees from becoming refugees i mean
is it
is if that happens is there really any
way to prevent what you're describing
i'd i'd like to know and i'd like to i'd
like to think that there is
yeah we're human beings we can we can
change our behavior
uh but we have to know about it we have
to be aware of it we have to be vigilant
and there have to be policies in place
to help us
and i just don't think we're
awake enough to the possibilities
to take the sorts of steps which will be
necessary that's one reason i wrote the
book
right dehumanization is an
ongoing problem and
to do something about it we have to
understand it
we have to understand how it works why
we are all vulnerable to dehumanizing
propaganda and what steps we might be
able to take to
at least constrain it the the book
is on inhumanity dehumanization
and how to resist it we've been speaking
with the book's author professor david
livingstone smith
an important topic and i appreciate you
joining me to talk about it today
i appreciate you inviting me the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we've been talking over the last couple
of weeks about this new wave
of very radical and also extraordinarily
ignorant i mean completely vapid on
policy trumpian members of congress
the three we've been focusing on are
marjorie taylor greene
lauren beaubert and madison cawthorne
and the last
24 to 48 hours have been an absolute
disaster for marjorie taylor greene to
the point that now democrats are
considering
mechanisms to expel her from congress
and even republicans really should be
thinking about how do we distance from
this
absolutely outrageous radical two new
uh uh not new two videos have now come
to light
um and in one of these videos i'm sure
many of you remember
the tragic and and uh
completely um uh disheartened i don't
even know what the word is to use for
the unconscionably tragic
shooting at marjory stoneman douglas
high school in parkland florida
and you may remember this activist david
hogg
who was a student at the time that the
school was
a victim to that mass shooting there is
video of marjorie taylor greene
um essentially harassing david hogg
following him on the street this was
first reported back
in june of last year it is again going
viral and i'm going to play the video in
its entirety for you this is this is
marjorie taylor green
a full-grown woman following david hogg
around washington dc harassing him
yeah david why are you supporting the
red flag laws
if there had been if scott peterson the
resource officer at parkland had done
his job
then nicholas cruz wouldn't have killed
anybody in your high school or at least
protected them
why are you supporting red flag gun laws
that attack our second amendment rights
and why are you using kids to get to as
a barrier
do you not know how to defend your
stance
look i'm an american citizen i'm a gun
owner i have a concealed carry permit i
carry a gun with
for protection for myself and you are
using your lobby and the money behind it
and the kids to try to take away my
second amendment rights
you don't have anything to say for
yourself
you can't defend your stance how did you
get
over 30 appointments with senators how'd
you do that
how did you get major press coverage on
this issue
and how did you get kids why do you use
kids
why kids you know if school if school
zones
were protected by with security guards
with guns
there would be no mass shootings at
with a schools but yet you're attacking
our second amendment
and you have nothing to say no words
don't walk it he's got nothing to say
sad he has nothing to say because there
really isn't anything to say you guys
he has nothing to say because he's paid
to do this
he has the walk away march he's got the
um
he's got the women's march and they're
funding all of this every town gun usa
they're funding all this stuff okay that
was david hogue right there
david we saw him inside the senate
building he had
30 30 um appointments where he ran
around and got to talk to senators
i got to talk to none none he had media
coverage all over the place
i had zero guess what i'm a gun owner
i'm an american citizen
and i have nothing but this guy with his
george soros funding
and his major liberal funding has got
everything
i want you to think about that that's
where we are and he's a coward he can't
say one word because he can't defend his
state
uh and this is not the only video of
marjorie taylor green
harassing people that is now uh sort of
being revived
here is one of marjorie taylor green
before she was elected this is february
of 2019.
she showed up at the house of
representatives
and was walking around the halls with a
bible
with the idea of finding congresswoman
ilhan omar and rashida talib
to get them to retake their oaths on a
bible rather than a quran
and you'll hear her talk incorrectly
about how the oath isn't valid if taken
on a quran which which is just not true
here's that video they signed that they
swore in on the
korean oh we have the bible we're going
to talk about swearing in on the
how to swear in on the bible with them
and let them know what our law says
that you can't swear in on the quran so
we're gonna we're gonna explain to that
you know we're gonna explain about how
you can't swear in on the quran
and we're gonna have the bible and ask
them if they would swear in
on the bible that we really need them
yeah we have the oath yep
so i think that's something the sad
thing is now that your
friends are in our religion you're
infringing on our religion
yes by saying that we can't swear but
when they swore in
it wasn't a law yet right at the time
they swore
i don't know i think at the time before
and that wasn't passed
because it wouldn't have been passed in
a republican control yeah so it was
passed
after they swore in so they're not
really official i don't think
so let's go ask them to swear in in the
bible because like you said
well i'm going to be the holy bible uh
yeah it has to be the bible
well the bottom line bottom line is
that's the bottom line how can you say
you represent women but you support
sharia law
this is currently an elected official
not just a low-level elected official
this
is one of 435 members of the u.s house
of representatives
and i don't care what happens to the
republican party
in terms of unity or
you know i i hope for the demise of the
republican party i think there would be
no better thing than donald trump
launching this third party he's
reportedly thinking of
and dividing the republican party if the
republican party has to fight off
trump's party
uh the patriot party or whatever it will
hopefully allow joe biden and democrats
and the more progressive elements of the
democratic party to get things done
that being said if republicans don't
denounce
marjorie taylor green's extremism if
they don't denounce the absurdity of
lauren beaubert if they don't denounce
the
just vapid politics of madison hawthorne
they're going to own it now maybe
they're okay with that
maybe republicans believe that they
should be going more
in this direction rather than going back
to not that it was what i agreed with
but more to the politics of people like
john mccain as an example or more in the
direction of someone like
mitt romney but the republican party now
has
it it's it's a contingent that i don't i
it's a conspiratorial
paranoid fringe radical element
that was not there before and there's
been a lot of radical stuff i mean
listen louie gohmert has been
matt gates these people these people are
bonkers but this is sort of just taking
it up to another level i'm not saying
anybody else is
is good i'm not saying i agree with
louis gomert
i'm just saying this is another level of
crazy and
uh marjorie taylor green also uh
unfortunately for her some facebook
posts were uncovered were years ago she
was talking about
killing democrats and i think her
defense is that lots of people help her
manage her page
basically saying it wasn't me who
actually posted it this is absolutely
disgusting depraved
uh stuff and for the sake of the
republican party
um they should say that this does not
represent us
democrats looking into how could she be
expelled from the house of
representatives i don't know how likely
that is to happen
but extraordinarily extraordinarily
disturbing stuff
hey this is very interesting we've been
thinking out loud
what is going to be the landing spot for
lots of former trump administration
officials and
one of the former administration
officials that
as the trump administration was winding
down i said
this person deserves this person should
be unhireable for the degree of
dishonesty
and humiliation that they participated
in uh during the trump administration i
was talking about
one of donald trump's former press
secretaries kaylee mcinanny
and uh we sort of said maybe she'll do
some kind of communication or consulting
for some right-wing group maybe she'll
become a pundit or go back to being a
pundit or something like that
crew the citizens for ethics watch
citizens for ethics i forget what the w
stands for citizens for ethics
i think watch they found a
uh they found in kaylee mcinanny's
financial disclosures
um an indication that kaylee had a gig
lined up with fox news and of course
that would not be in any way
surprising to us there is a sort of
revolving door
in fact between fox news and the trump
administration
trump often even thinking of hiring
people
after seeing them on fox news this
document
was exposed and it was revealed that
kaylee mcinanni reached an agreement
with fox news
to start working there this month
however after this was revealed
um there was a statement put out by fox
news
saying simply kaylee mcinanni is not
currently an employee or contributor at
fox news
what may have happened here and at this
point it is mere speculation
is that while the agreement was in place
early in january for kaylee to start at
fox news
the january 6th riots and just the
disaster that ended up being the final
days of the trump administration
made fox rethink at least temporarily
this deal
and while i think it is completely
plausible that in a month in two months
and six months who knows kaylee mcinanni
is going to show up as a contributor on
fox news it seems maybe they have just
paused it and they're deciding to delay
this
and if you look at the very carefully
worded statement from fox news again
their only statement was kaylee mcinanni
is not currently an employee
or contributor at fox news it seems as
though they are choosing to
delay that now there were also other
really interesting things in kaylee
mcinanny's financial disclosure
one is that the on-campus right-wing
group
turning point usa which is
charlie kirk is the guy who's known to
be the sort of
public-facing figure of that
organization turning point usa
paid for a 6 500
gift for kaylee and a guest to go to an
event
in which she received an award okay in
december
kaylee went to the winter gala at
mar-a-lago
and there were obviously questions about
what there's a
there's a pandemic what the hell are
they doing she was given an award
by turning point usa at trump's
mar-a-lago
and she was given a 6 500 gift she also
reported receiving close to two hundred
thousand dollars
in salary and bonus from the trump
campaign
and rnc um and
that includes a few months before she
started working at the white house
but it is reported that she was still
getting paid
12 000 or more
by the campaign after working at the
white house campaign employee
government employee same time while
getting gifts from turning point usa
and making deals with fox news while uh
still the press secretary of the united
states
it's wacky stuff i don't think any of us
will find this to be even
remotely surprising if we were wondering
about
the trajectory on fox news for the next
couple of years
hiring one of the biggest trump liars
and sycophants hints to me
that they're not planning on getting
away from the trumpy stuff they
in fact they may fox news may have to go
more pro-trump
in order to compete with oan and newsmax
remember that in the aftermath
of trump not being able to steal the
election from joe biden
many fox news viewers abandoned fox news
and went over to oan
and or newsmax and this is a a real
issue for fox news if they
believe that they need to go more trumpy
to maintain or regain their audience
where do the traditional conservatives
go not that i care but i am certainly
curious about that and if republicans
learn nothing from trump
and move further in the trumpian
direction
do the traditional republicans become
centrist democrats i i'm genuinely
unsure
i don't feel bad for them the
traditional republicans starting with
ronald reagan in the 1980s
going to newt gingrich in the 1990s they
benefited from the same
anti-intellectualism uh that led
to trump so i don't feel bad for them at
all it's merely a curiosity where do
they go if fox news goes full
trump um for now kaylee mcinanni will
not be joining
fox news we have a voicemail number that
number
is 219 to david p
here is a bernie voter who so far
is pleased with joe biden take a listen
david i was a big bernie supporter
and i wasn't naive enough to think that
voting for somebody else would benefit
the democrats or my beliefs as a
progressive
so i voted for biden and voting for
biden right now and like you said in the
first six or seven days he's
actually already impressed me i
understand it's only executive orders
and nothing's been
brought to the senate or the house yet
but i actually feel
more optimistic than i originally did
and i'm really excited about it and
thanks david
and by the way this is stewart from
wisconsin and his wife jenny thank you
sure it's still too busy i like the
yellow one remind me of star trek a
little bit
all right thanks dude appreciate
everything was that my
sweater is filthy busy i've never heard
that
i don't know what the kids these days
are talking about but i've never heard
that before
uh i think that that's very interesting
to hear and i've heard from a bunch of
bernie supporters
who are saying so far i mean for the
first week of joe biden
he's really actually done quite a few
things including things like
freezing a saudi arms deal that i think
very few people expected him to do
certainly within the first week so
we will continue tracking and holding
joe biden accountable but
much to be pleased about in the first
seven or eight days
we have much to talk about on today's
bonus show
including this is crazy china is
deploying an anal swab
for covid testing why why is this
necessary we will talk about the medical
elements involved there
uh also the pence's mike and karen are
apparently homeless and couch surfing
right now what is going on with that
and more on the game stop short squeeze
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com i'll see you there
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99 dollars a month with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started